[Music]
foreign
[Music]
to the reason Roundtable your weekly
podcast from the libertarian magazine
we're giving Tuesday lasts for eight
days yes that's another plug for annual
webathon please go right now right the
hell now to reason.com donate I am Matt
Welch joined by Nicholas B Peter
souderman Catherine mangyu Ward happy
repeal day everyone hi Matt howdy happy
repeal day
you know it was like a Hanukkah right
there what was that he was happy it was
like it's a Hanukkah Miracle our giving
Tuesday we thought we had enough giving
for one Tuesday but it lasted eight days
when you uh you know you just give until
your heart bleeds until your lip bleeds
speaking of bleeding let's get right
into uh the weekends kerfuffles uh we
try on this program
um to not necessarily be the proverbial
dog chasing the proverbial squirrel
Peter
uh because sometimes
uh nothing just it's more squirrels
they're day rats as we all know
um no because of the important things
happen on uh every day important bad
things happen with the government and
others uh things every day and attention
Seekers tend to suck up attention and
don't necessarily want to look at it all
the time but nevertheless Elon Musk and
sometimes Donald Trump keep persisting
on late Friday afternoon
the Mercurial new owner of Twitter
announced that he would soon be
publishing the Twitter files with uh
noted journalist and commentator Matt
taibi on lead tweet what came next was a
sometimes strange uh but very
interesting thread of some 40 odd tweets
from taibi describing some of the
context behind why and how the social
media company under pressure from
politicians and others in the politics
business among others took the
extraordinary step in the fall of 2020
of suppressing a New York Post article
about the discovered contents of Hunter
Biden's laptop which included a bunch of
salacious slash pathetic uh party picks
of the then Presidential candidates Sons
cavorting with hired gal Pals as well as
information about various Shady looking
overseas business deals among Twitter's
heavy-handed actions at the time was
just flat out Banning the New York post
from Twitter for more than a week
as the Twitter files revealed Twitter's
um ad hoc justification for the
suppression was that the story violated
its hacked materials policy even though
there was no evidence that the materials
were hacked indeed despite many news
organizations broadcasting and repeating
as fact various National Security
mouthpieces saying at the time that the
story had all the Hallmarks of Russian
disinformation campaign years later we
now know the laptop and its ugly
contents were very much real a couple
reactions to the Twitter files worth
briefly noting
scores of journalists including those
who work for the very same Publications
that were poo pooing the story two years
ago uh just heaped derision all over
taibi including his former employer
Rolling Stone who called it a snooze
Fest and referred to taibi as a
sub-stack blogger and former president
Donald Trump suggested that the massive
and widespread fraud and deception made
the 2020 election eligible for
nullification perhaps riding on his
social media site that quote a massive
fraud of this type and magnitude allows
for the termination of all rules
regulations and articles even those
found in the Constitution
uh lots to chew on here Catherine
uh why don't you lead us off what do you
learn in the Twitter files both in their
uh contents and the reaction thereof so
I'm I'm soft launching a new uh
politician that I don't completely hate
today uh which was Ro Kahana who
um I had previously suspected I might
not completely hate
um he and I were on Bill Maher together
and uh also he's done some good stuff on
the CJ sirimella beat
um with respect to
um Shoring up Fourth Amendment
protections but
um you know Robbie Suave wrote this up
for us uh as as the the Twitter
Bombshells were dropping and basically
said
um these are not Bombshells which was
certainly my main takeaway that there
was not a lot in there that we didn't
already know or suspect
and you know in this sort of horrible
way that one can be disappointed when
the worst thing doesn't happen I was
like disappointed the the the
malfeasance was not at the levels I had
feared or something right so I mean
there was absolutely a scenario here
where there could have been a you know
not too cliche but let's go ahead and do
it Smoking Gun uh in which we had kind
of a sitting government official maybe
um you know Biden adjacent specifically
asking for these stories to be
suppressed that's not really what we saw
and in the case of rokana we saw
um actually like an extremely sensible
note saying like this is a bad idea and
you shouldn't do this
um not quite getting the First Amendment
right in my view the First Amendment
does not speak one way or tether about
whether Twitter lets the New York Post
share stories but um otherwise
directionally correct
um and as Robbie noted
um some of those folks actually come off
looking better than expected in those
exchanges
um but yes the uh
the the big the big bombshell was
actually a little
a little Cherry Bomb
Peter there's some fuzz uh is there not
uh with that line between government
um uh pressure and what Twitter did
there was uh somewhere in the in the 20s
or 30s uh in the numbered tweets of of
Tybee on Friday uh afternoon late
um there was a group uh or a
representative of a group that had
corralled
um sentiment among 12 members of
Congress who were on I think the
Judiciary Committee and said to Twitter
uh basically you're gonna get a pretty
rough treatment
um on the next committee meeting if this
doesn't happen is that not if not a
First Amendment violation isn't is that
a thing that happens and should we be
worried about that on free speechy and
even First Amendment D grounds so that
was net Choice which is a trade industry
Tech group uh right that their business
is that they kind of communicate between
the tech industry and that's not one
specific company it's a bunch of member
companies they communicate between the
tech industry and uh Congress and sort
of and lawmakers and policy makers right
that's their business uh net choice is
um is a group that I think uh you know
we have um in some cases uh talk to uh
here at reason um I certainly I believe
we we know some of the folks over there
uh and what they were just saying was
they were communicating what was likely
to happen because that is their business
right and now you can I think so to be
clear I don't think that net that
netchoice did anything wrong in
communicating that because that's net
Choice's job is to communicate what
they're hearing on the hill and what
they're hearing in Washington I think if
you um you want to make an argument that
there was something you know sort of
shady going on there it was uh or or
something untoward you have to to say
well it's the policy makers who are
saying we're going to come you know who
are communicating through back channels
we're going to come down on you if you
do this at the same time that those
policy makers were um if I understand
correctly saying uh basically don't
block this story don't uh restrict all
of this because that will be a problem
for you and indeed it is in a a kind of
a has been a kind of a problem for
Twitter not necessarily in the sense
that it resulted in direct you know
legislation against Twitter or uh you
know similar sorts of companies but in
the sense that Republicans have made a
big political issue out of this at the
same time
I I think that the takeaway here is how
little the government was involved in
this very specific story so not that
long ago you had Matt taibi who was the
person that uh as far as I can tell Elon
Musk hand-picked to deliver this
information to the world right it seems
pretty clear that musk approached taibi
to do this story I think that's maybe
not perfectly established but certainly
musk is the person who excuse me taibi
is the person who did it and musk gave
him permission to do so
and not that long ago you had taibi
tweeting stuff like the laptop is by far
the secondary issue the real problem is
the FBI stepping in to cut distribution
of the true story so it was taibi saying
it was FBI pressure that was the real
story here and then I just want to read
you in full tweet number 22 from this
tweet store although several sources
recalled hearing about a general warning
from federal law enforcement that summer
about possible foreign hacks so I'm
gonna now step in and just footnote this
that means this is a general warning
that doesn't have to do specifically
with the hunter Biden laptop story and
predated it
then back to Tybee there's no evidence
that I've seen of any government
involvement in the laptop story in fact
that might have been the problem is
taibi's conclusion which I want to say
is not mine
my conclusion here first of all is
actually just that that articles are
good and Twitter threads are less good
and while I wasn't annoyed that tahipi
put this on Twitter first rather than on
his sub stack to which I'm a subscriber
I was kind of annoyed that there was no
eventual sub stack version just kind of
rounding it up in like a sort of clean
article-like way now my conclusion here
is that this was almost entirely just
Collective stupidity and cowardice led
by like in inept ideologically inclined
management and out to lunch CEO and this
wasn't a conspiracy this wasn't really a
sort of this wasn't big government
pressure so much as clumsiness and
stupidity on the part of the people
managing the platform perhaps
ideologically inclined clumsiness and
stupidity perhaps partisan clumsiness
and stupidity on the part of the
managers but it wasn't this sort of deep
nefarious thing it was just just a bunch
of bone-headed decisions that blew up
there's a reading of that taibi
referenced to government not having its
fingerprints is that it was a reference
to foreign government that he was not
precluding FBI involvement and it wasn't
addressing that just to throw that out
there um but and speaking of that Nick
at the time uh and the New York Post has
had a pretty memorable cover story that
showed the preponderance of people who
came out and there are a lot of ex-fbi
EX Director of National Intelligence
deep State actor deep State Nick
Gillespie the actor Studio of the deep
State actors so many contributor
contracts to CNN and MSNBC who um came
out and pooh-poohed the story as having
the Hallmarks of Russian disinformation
and uh and so many journalistic outlets
and facts Checkers uh said basically the
same thing and were very like scenery at
the those who are like hey why aren't
you covering this story is that not an
ongoing uh kind of Scandal and uh uh and
and one that continues to erode trust in
institutions absolutely yeah uh you know
and I mean to kind of pick up on some of
what Peter was saying you know what I
took away from this was that Twitter and
I don't know that it has this under Elon
Musk but under Jack Dorsey who I am very
favorably disposed towards I think Jack
Dorsey is one of the most Visionary and
important and forward-looking uh you
know major business people uh you know
CEO types tech people around his he was
you know the CEO of two companies
Twitter needs a CEO who is focused
simply on Twitter and not Twitter plus a
bunch of other things
um what I took away from it was the way
that people below him kind of all
cobbled together a really awful decision
um I think it's more informed by their
interactions with government people or
spokespeople for government people when
you see you know who gave money to uh
you know at Twitter who you know what
kind of politicians do they give what
kind of open channels did they have when
they were getting requests from
politically motivated or politically
connected people to say hey can you can
you get rid of this tweet can you end
this can you end that it's not that it's
it isn't a um a conspiracy that you
would see in a you know an
anti-communist movie from the 1950s or
something where you know the Kremlin is
calling up somebody and says a code word
and then suddenly everybody acts in a
particular you know like in its dominoes
it you know just going down the chain of
command or anything like that but it
shows how decision making gets made and
more importantly how group think in
organizations really concretizes into
just stupid ideas that take forever to
come back there's Tweets in there it
talks about how long it took Jack Dorsey
to even understand what was going on and
whatnot and then it was hard to reverse
and I think Matt that New York Post
story you're talking about which is kind
of stunning where there's all of these
people and mediaite has a great Roundup
of uh you know responses to the current
Twitter files thread that just came out
that is very similar to the critiques
that were launched at the time it's
always trying to will it away uh you
know group think is the major problem
and group think can come from you know
it can come from kind of direct
government pressure or Worse still I
think it comes from kind of soft
pressure where people think they're
doing the right thing or they're
agonizing to do the right thing when
it's not right and they're not being
pressured to do it directly
Catherine building on that concept one
of the pieces of information that I
think were treated as an aha by one side
and a snooze Fest on the other uh is
some of the throat clearing at the top
of the thread about you know 98 99 of
donations from inside the Twitter house
that were or earmarked for politics went
to Democrats
um you being someone who neither votes
nor has a natural rooting interest in in
either side
um
to next point is is that uh some
preponderance like that a 98 to 99 like
a Cuban election style tilt within an
institution that interfaces with
government and the media is that a
significant thing uh and would we treat
it really differently if it was 98 to 99
Republicans
yeah I mean I think we are used to those
kinds of numbers in many of the let's
say Elite institutions that shape our
lives right so this is also true in
universities for the most part and those
universities churn out schmancy
knowledge workers and then those
schmancy knowledge workers go work at
Twitter and there's probably some
additional filtering um that that
further Narrows the political bias or
reduces political diversity I guess you
could say I think it's relevant
information I just think most people
want to then take that relevant
information and do the wrong thing with
it so
um you know you sometimes hear this even
from
some of my most favoritest and sanest
right-wingers like Jonah Goldberg and
David French you know we have to take
back the institution like the fact that
these institutions are so overwhelmingly
left-leaning or Democratic leaning shows
that it is time for some kind of major
action and I just don't know I mean I I
don't know what that major action would
be like the major action is like start
truth social or whatever the major
action is uh start
um whatever the uh University of Austin
Austin University what's that thing
called the University of Austin but
that's great right like started
start your own thing um I know that it
like start your own thing is out of
fashion now but screw you guys I'm
always out of fashion so let's do it and
and then beyond that I don't think there
is a huge amount of Remedy you can take
seriously the fact that the bias exists
and that that's going to inform outputs
like everybody group thinking their way
to Banning this story
but I also think the deeper problem is
just like people want to believe in
their guy I mean Sim this is a perfect
parallel to the National Enquirer Trump
you know Revelations early in in uh um
in the first campaign where people who
already liked Trump said oh the source
is incredible and who knows and it's all
rumors and anyway it's probably not
relevant to the election by and then
never thought about it again and that's
what people who liked Biden hoped would
happen with the hunter Biden stuff
Twitter as is predicted throughout the
taibi thread we have people over and
over and over saying guys this is going
to cause a backlash it's going to do the
opposite of the thing you hoped and that
did turn out to be true
um
but
people are on a team but everyone's on a
team we're on a team like you know I'm
team neither of these jerk faces in this
particular case but makes it hard to
print uniforms you know we are we reason
staff is also overwhelmingly part of a
shared uh a shared ideological bet now
we say it out loud on purpose we put it
right there on our cover and I think
that's a better way but
um yeah I don't think it's that
surprising to learn that Twitter is
super super biased in that way and
humans are making some of these
decisions so that's going to matter the
Jersey it's two jerk faces with a no
sign around it look at the smoking sign
you know there's a real move to dismiss
this as a you know uh this is nothing
you know we've already seen this let's
move on I mean it's you know it's the
it's just a dress with a presidential
Seaman staying on it there's nothing new
here let's just get on with our lives
this type of thing it's really great to
see inside the Skunk Works of how the
hive mind and the group think at Twitter
played out because there are corporate
structures that could have been put in
place or business practices that would
have served as more checks on that like
you know obviously every system is prone
to failure and everything like that but
you know Twitter is not is not an
ideological uh monthly publication you
know it's supposed to be if only
something that allows people to
communicate in real time and I actually
part of the most important thing that
Matt taibi wrote is you know the
beginning uh you know like the throat
clearing as you called it Matt where he
was talking about how you know what
Twitter did did is it allowed real-time
you know a real-time mass media audience
to form around particular topics and
that's what was so exciting about it and
that's what was so meaningful about it
um and kind of getting back to something
like that would be fantastic
um and hopefully that'll happen under
Elon Musk I'm not sure but you get in
the way when you have people who are
like I don't like this story and so
we're gonna you know we're gonna create
a system where we're all like timid and
scared and full of [ __ ] and end up
censoring a story that's both real and
relevant so I do think that Twitter and
musk are to be commended here for the
just for the transparency even if the
form is somewhat frustrating and even if
the revelations are maybe somewhat less
than people had hoped for the group that
comes off worst out of all of this is
the Russian paranoia intelligence
community that was warning that Hunter
Biden's laptop top was obviously Russian
disinformation if we go back just a
couple of months to September Olivia
nussie had a great story in New York
Magazine uh sort of going back over this
in which she contacted James Clapper and
Michael Hayden both of whom had signed a
letter that got published in Politico
under the headline Hunter Biden's story
is Russian disinfo dozens of former
Intel officials say and she asked them
so so what do you think now that we know
it's real and both of them basically
just got really mad that she was asking
about it
she should have asked Jonathan shait uh
while she was at it that would have been
pretty sweet
um he wrote a lot of Articles you know
the other thing one of the odd and
unanticipated outcomes of all this is
like Hunter Biden has become
like more humanized I think
um you know partly he I mean he
obviously had his own Memoir and things
like that but somehow it shift the story
has shifted to him as you know gripless
meth addict with a with a [ __ ] problem
to
um uh you know as opposed to the useless
son who of of of a you know a very well
positioned politician who's going to
China and Ukraine and elsewhere to just
make make lots of money I mean he was
like you know he went from being uh
Billy Carter on meth to you know being
kind of a lovable uh you know
presidential [ __ ] up to like Roger
Clinton or something like that this is a
very particular interpretation of events
Nick I'm not I'm not sure that America
joins you in seeing Hunter Biden as a
lovable [ __ ] up
he's disappearing he's he's moving I
mean he should be but because it's
really ultimately not about it no that's
true in fact like the malfeasance of
those around him with respect to his
[ __ ] ups was was actually on so much of
a larger scale that that became the
story but that's not to Hunter Biden's
credit that's to the discredit of those
who managed to [ __ ] up even worse than
leaving their laptop full of
incriminating cabinets somehow for Rudy
Giuliani to find which is a pretty
substantial [ __ ] up
I think at this point I don't know if
Hillary Clinton and Chelsea Clinton are
still driving around the country taping
podcasts like they were a couple weeks
ago it would be great if they got Hunter
Biden to join them in the car and maybe
they pick up Rudy Giuliani at a Sinclair
station somewhere in the uh petrified
forest or something
Jeff Flake starts uh uh cutting coconuts
rare chested just to just to tie the
room together Jeff like must be very
upset that he ever left that Island yeah
we all are honestly I want to share a
particularly ridiculous headline I I've
I have found a lot of the media reaction
to this to be
um just telling on itself this comes
from the rap which is a Hollywood based
thing
um Elon Musk is turning Hunter Biden's
penis into a constitutional crisis no
joke
no none of that no stop it you don't
have to do that it's not no uh there's a
an attempt in the minimization of the
story to make it all about
um Hunter Biden's very uh visible if
you're gonna go through the uh various
files uh penis
um but uh the thing that makes the story
newsworthy is that um he was involved in
all kinds of overseas deals worth
millions of dollars with unsavory people
um and he was making references to uh
people and that we would like to know
who those people were um Hunter Biden
does not come off as a guy who has some
kind of natural uh winning uh business
Acumen and yet got himself some pretty
good jobs it's worth looking into like
fundamentally
um I want to uh make sure that we touch
on this notion
here because uh I I read the uh uh
Donald Trump uh quote at the at the top
here there is a notion not just from
Trump but from a lot of his supporters
and maybe even people who are lukewarm
towards him but who believe that the
2020 election
um that there were uh uh definitely
thumbs on the scale it was the outcome
of it was impacted by decisions
um by social media companies and also by
media media companies to suppress this
story in particular and that uh it
affected things
um it is a similar accusation that one
heard a lot of in 2016 and after 2016.
when it came to Facebook and Russians
and and uh ads and and uh Cambridge
analytica I even forget what they do but
somehow they did it I think they sell
encyclopedias door-to-door yeah I hope
so uh
it's it's uh uh
epididymis is
you guys remember that Mike Jimmy Wales
a side hustle actually yeah
uh my question to the group uh that we
can do quickly is uh do we think
Catherine you can start uh do we think
that this impacted the 2020 election
um and do we think that the Facebook
rusky whatever
um impacted the 2016 election in any
measurable way uh and how do we how do
we assess them I think it's really hard
to assess that I think the Baseline
question hey what if Twitter's internal
governance decisions did impact the
election like
it's a it's okay if they did
like I don't I didn't enjoy it I don't
think this was like a maximally healthy
way to do fact-finding about our
candidates but you know the whole the
whole thing around political speech like
the whole thing about the media and
social media is that like many of us are
out here talking about what might happen
in an election and who deserves to win
an election and what the policy
implications of that would be and what
the personality and character
implications of that would be and if it
so happens that a private company
made a decision or you know published or
didn't publish speech that swayed an
election like that's legal that's okay
now again the thing that I was looking
for in this taibi thread that was mostly
not there
and that I will be interested to hear if
we if we learn more about other less hot
button
um instances of kind of promotion or
suppression of certain types of content
especially covid misinformation quote
unquote misinformation
um but
this was not government chilling or
prohibiting or censoring speech that
would be wrong bad alarming Etc
um Russians buying a couple of ads
showing Jesus arm wrestling Donald Trump
in 2016
on Facebook I don't think that impacted
the election but if it did like that is
no different than candidates running ads
that is no different than newspaper
endorsements of candidates that is no
different than any man that is no
different than standing on the street
corner with a sign like this is all
protected speech and should be and
um isn't there a difference when it's a
foreign government buying the ad
especially when it's a foreign
government pretending not to be a
foreign government well it's technically
illegal yeah that's my point that's my
it is technically illegal uh my like
smoking hot take I guess is like I don't
think it should be I don't know it's not
enforceable and also like we let foreign
individuals speak in this country and in
general I find campaign Finance
restrictions of all kinds to be largely
in violation of both the letter and the
spirit of the First Amendment
um I get it I get why those laws exist
and I want to take like a you know
that's like very low on my list of laws
to eliminate is the thing that prohibits
like Russia from purchasing every ad in
Times Square for them the day before the
election or whatever but that would be
so great
um but it's like arm wrestling pictures
but yeah these all these things probably
did influence the election that's how we
do elections everyone tries to influence
everyone and then we see who wins
anything to add gents uh yeah you know
it's I don't I don't think it was
determinative uh which is a different
way of saying what Catherine's getting
at everything kind of matters the fact
of the matter
is that Biden smoked Trump he beat him
handily it was not close and this story
had it gone out uh as done because it
did get a huge amount of attention I
don't think it would have been the
Difference Maker
um in this and that doesn't mean I I am
more worried about the way in which
corporations or large platforms large
media Outlets
um either that are news focused like CNN
or Fox News
um you know do things or places like
Twitter which presume and present as if
they are Arbiters of fairness and are
just kind of letting people go
you know they need to do better they uh
Twitter absolutely needs to do better
this is one of the reasons why I like
Jack Dorsey uh in Congressional
testimony he said this was a mistake and
it won't happen again
um you know obviously he's no longer in
charge of the company but it was bad but
it didn't change the outcome of the
election any more than Fox News
broadcasting all of the Swift boat vet
stuff which was mostly horseshit against
us in 2004.
um you know that's not the reason why
John Kerry lost he lost because he kept
running over secret servicemen while
snowboarding
you didn't salute hard enough Peter uh
yeah so I think it's hard to know
whether it um was determinative in the
election I if I had to betch
um I would bet that it wasn't and here's
the thing this Twitter made a bad
decision but Twitter's bad decision did
not keep the information from getting
out into the world it was not actually
suppressed from public discourse the New
York Post still published the story the
New York Post story ran and was
available online people were able to
talk about it um even in some cases on
Twitter there was one person who
published the story as a tweet thread
and somehow or another got it through at
least for some of the time yes there was
absolutely bad decision making on
Twitter's part but it's at least
possible like you can imagine it's hard
to know because it's a counter factual
but you can imagine that Twitter making
the decision to suppress this story and
then having a whole bunch of discussion
about the suppression of the story
actually meant that it got more
publicity and more people heard about it
and so I I just think that it's bizarre
to to suggest that this this one bad
decision by Corp by Twitter's corporate
management was the thing that that
changed the election and like uh that
determined the outcome of the election
and like Catherine I also believe that
if it was then that wouldn't necessarily
be a problem
all right uh we're gonna get to our
listener email of the week here in a
moment
but first friends you might think you've
done everything in your power to ensure
your family in the case of a medical
emergency but what many of us don't
realize is that health insurance won't
always cover the full cost of for
example an emergency medical flight if
you require Air transport even
comprehensive coverage can leave you
with high deductibles and co-pays that's
where air Med Care Network comes in when
you sign up to become a member of the
air Medcare Network should any such
emergency arise you will not see a bill
for air Medical Transport when flown by
a provider intermed care transports more
than 100 000 patients each and every
year that's about a dozen just during
the duration of this podcast this peace
of mind for you and your whole family
can be yours beginning at the low low
price of just 85 a year listeners the
round table can get gift cards with
their new memberships for up to fifty
dollars through either Visa or Amazon
simply visit
airmedcarnetwork.com reason and use the
offer code reason and start protecting
your family do it today you'll be glad
you did okay reminder to send us your
pithy emails to Roundtable at reason.com
and thanks again uh to everyone who sent
all those Wild and Woolly emails that we
tried to plow through for the bonus
videotaped webathon episode of
Roundtable last week
this one comes from Jason H who writes
in part
here in my hometown of NYC where
apparently the carpetbagger Gillespie
has chosen to make his home
just earlier today the Adams
Administration stated its intention to
increase involuntary hospitalizations
for homes individuals suffering from
severe mental illness essentially they
are seeking to expand the interpretation
of the legal standard from hospitalizing
those who are likely to cause serious
harm to themselves or others to those
whose mental illness prevents them from
meeting their basic survival needs of
food clothing shelter or medical care
end quote notwithstanding the legitimate
concerns over the state and involuntary
hospitalizations appearing in the same
sentence or nightmare scenarios about
who may be labeled unable to meet their
basic needs perhaps someone consuming a
large soda would the round table care to
weigh in on Where the Line may be here
at what point if ever should the state
involuntarily hospitalize and or
medicate someone to protect themselves
or those around them Nixons who were
invoked why don't you go first yeah yeah
I will get to the substance of the
letter but I just want to point out
unless Jason H is older than 59 I was
loading diapers in the Flatlands
neighborhood of Brooklyn in 1963 pal so
boom not a carpet bagger I'm gonna
choose to imagine you Nick as a baby
just like putting pallets of diapers on
a truck that's I'm sure I was you know I
was precocious I'm gonna imagine you for
the cloth type with one of those good
American launchers that they use it like
basketball games except you're loading
the T-shirt launcher that's right cloth
diapers yuck you batch of loaded diapers
which I believe isn't that the name of
the older Brothers Band in Middle School
the Worst Years of uh my life
or I or maybe in a Diary of a Wimpy Kid
might be in Diary yeah it might be one
of either yeah one of those yeah
you may now answer the question oh yeah
um I'm actually uh well a couple of
things uh and I I suspect on this call
as well as in uh libertarian World more
directly I am more sympathetic to
involuntary commitment of homeless
people or of picking them up
um and what and this is partly born out
of having lived for part of the uh
pandemic in Los Angeles particularly
Venice uh where there was no attempt to
even assess the mental health needs of
people or help them get off the street
in a voluntary way
um in New York they are you know fairly
stringent they house a lot of the
homeless people at night when the
temperature goes below a certain amount
they have people who come around and
actually coax people and say hey do you
want to stay somewhere
Etc they move them to shelters and
things like that and it's one of the
reasons why the homeless population in
New York is not as bad as it is uh or
you know as problematic as it is in
places like LA and San Francisco that
refused to do that this you know
involuntary commitment has to be a very
very high bar but by the same token I
think the complete unwillingness of many
Libertarians to talk about mental
illness in public spaces and the effect
that that has not simply on the
individual itself but on actual quality
of life is is a problem we need to be
talking about this more just the other
day in a subway station there was a
semi-naked guy on a big piece of
cardboard in a train station shouting
and screaming at police officers
incoherently I don't know what happened
um but like I don't think
yeah you know after they after they put
me in uh jail and gave me some uh you
know some drugs and shock treatment you
know I really my memory is just not so
good anymore all I think about is
loading diapers uh no but like seriously
um you know I didn't stick around to see
how that ended but you know that's an
issue
um and you know mentally the mental
illness that is actually real
um needs to be addressed uh when it
starts moving into the streets and
threatening people as well as harming
the people who are evidencing it
Catherine will you let this this uh this
uh Pro uh involuntary commitment
sentiment stand I mean I I'm not sure I
can I can make Nick sit or stand any
kind of way but uh but yeah so I I will
say I actually have become uh
increasingly
um sazian as as I get older um that is
uh increasingly convinced by at least
parts of Thomas saz's argument which is
pretty deep in reasons DNA
um that in many cases
diagnoses of mental illness or
allegations of insanity are sort of
become tools of state power
and also uh the sort of more extreme
version uh maybe a caricature of his
view depending on who you listen to so
mental illness doesn't exist at all um
that there's literally no such thing as
mental illness
um I do not think that
um but I do see I can see in front of me
um partially thanks to some you know
original reporting by reason that uh
that very clearly we do use diagnoses
and mental illness as as weapons of
state power that we do imprison people I
think we can see this in the way that we
handle sex offenders
um where kind of criminal conduct and
mental illness overlap in confusing ways
um the kind of interminable commitment
in which there is no there's no clear
way out for many sex offenders
especially in California
um that makes me very very wary of
saying anything that sounds anything
like maybe we need to be doing more of
this and I agree that
um the kind of you know whatever we're
calling it these days urban disorder
often powered by by people who are not
fully in charge of their their mental
their mental state but but again just
just very very very very very very
hesitant to say we should lock people up
like we we as Libertarians um and I
think it's just like compassionate
people should absolutely consider that
the last app I'm not saying Nick is not
doing that but I I think that the you
know seeing seeing this in front of you
seeing um kind of for reasons like I
don't think people are more mentally ill
than they were you know five years ago
there are other factors that are pushing
people into the streets right now there
are surveys showing that at least
amongst people who are sort of let's say
somewhat more functioning not homeless
there is actually at least more
self-reported um
related covert related depression and
whatever is leading someone to be
screaming naked on the subway platform I
think are are what's going to do with
that person though because I I don't
think we're talking about like you know
you have I and I have an aunt who had
this in in the 40s she was kind of
mouthy and she ended up getting shock
treatment yeah because it's like what
the [ __ ] you know that that's one
scenario when you have somebody who is
standing on a street corner and I've
seen this on uh you know Bleaker Street
in Lafayette taking a [ __ ] in the middle
of the day on the street corner are you
just like hey you be you but you'd be
the best you you can be or do they get
arrested do they get a summons through I
mean like that's I mean this is where I
think most people are talking about I
agree but this is where I actually think
that the we have to address the root
causes people are right I mean like
there is the sort of specific acute
moment but why are there so many more
specific acute moments right now it's
not because more people are
schizophrenic it's not because more
people are suddenly desperately
seriously mentally ill it's because of a
bunch of other things that are going on
including economic factors including
um you know including the way that
there's all kinds of stuff here the way
we handle zoning the way we handle
welfare benefits the way our medical
system is working and how over text it
is right now like yeah but Catherine you
gotta remember move the pooper you gotta
remove the pooper you know I'm not I'm
not gonna go hard on you can't arrest
the pooper right now but I really know
that's a question like you remove
remember where and then it becomes an
interesting you know and I'm I'm saucya
I'm sauzy and plus fukultian so I get
almost all diagnosis or all
categorization whether it's by the state
or a doctor or by a relative is a form
of power to kind of control people's
behavior but you take that person if you
put them into you know the prison system
or the criminal justice system you know
there's a reason why they're supposedly
you know like 300 000 mentally ill
people in federal prisons alone because
we're not treating them for mental
illness or we're not giving them the
tools or the drugs or something to come
back but I mean
you know it it seems like it's it's a
real issue you know like the the person
screaming on the street corner can't be
can't just you can't just let that
happen all day long and all night long I
I'm basically somewhere between Nick and
Catherine on this maybe not surprisingly
uh the thing that I want to add to this
discussion that has not been brought up
too much is that
um first when you say we're gonna expand
the use of involuntary commitment the
more you which is what Adams is saying
right here is the more you expand it the
more power the states takes to to to to
do that the more likely there is for
abuse or misapplication right because
um the the street pooper and Nick's aunt
exist in some sense on a Continuum right
like on the one hand there's somebody
who's clearly not in control of their
faculties and having like a deep
breakdown of their ability to function
as a normal human being and then on the
other hand there is a person who is
a little bit annoying at a at the dinner
table and somewhere in between there's
like the point at which the state stops
intervening uh or I guess in this case
the state didn't stop at the annoying at
the dinner table level and you have to
and like it's very very difficult to
draw that line and inevitably I mean
just look at CJ siermello's reporting on
Florida
um and and some of the the involuntary
commitment abuses there right you just
see that when the state takes more power
to says we're going to do more of it
then that means there is more potential
for abuse at the margins even if most of
the cases are are people who we could
agree are really having a lot of trouble
in their lives the other thing I would
say is that during the pandemic and in
the aftermath of the pandemic
we saw governments all over the country
local governments for the most part shut
down attempts by Charities to house and
help uh the homeless and the Christian
britsky has reported on this for us to
great effect and read his reporting it
is just incredibly infuriating churches
local community groups that wanted to
have say places where people could sleep
in cars or wanted to build things to
build facilities where they could house
homeless people got caught up in zoning
rules and all sorts of stupid local
politics and people just saying well you
know we don't want that in our
neighborhood and the result is that some
neighborhood ends up with a homeless
Camp rather than
um rather than a shelter where people
can actually sleep and be off of the
streets and so I think as Libertarians
you know we might we might say okay look
the guy who's flinging Pooh on the
street that guy he should probably end
up in some sort of facility and you can
say right like the extreme cases maybe
you can say that there's some sort of
role for the the state there but the
thing we should be most focused on the
thing that I think that Libertarians
should should pay attention to most are
the ways in which the state is actually
making uh is actually exacerbating this
problem by stopping Charities
um and then also by abusing its power to
take in people who do not need to be
committed
I will say I saw like just a really
great I can't remember it was a tweet or
a post of some kind uh that was just
like um activist for mental health
um you know for for mental illness
acceptance uh wishes for a world in
which there's more visibility and
understanding of mental illness the
monkey's paw curls right because we now
have a world with like a huge amount of
visibility and discourse about mental
illness both in this extreme example of
kind of
um again I hate this term I wish I could
think of a better term Urban disorder
stuff but also you know every 18 year
old in America now has like
disassociative identity disorder or
whatever
um it's kind of cool and trendy to be
mentally ill and the two sides of that
spectrum and sort of the way that we are
swinging between them is going to
produce some really really dysfunctional
outcomes in terms of the policy sphere
and maybe also in terms of the clinical
sphere so that I think we are still at
the beginning of screwing this up quite
badly and so I just you know I don't
want to look back later and say hey I'm
a Libertarian but but like Nick said a
bunch of butts in his answer and like
those those butts like I don't want to
be a part of yeah because then a John
soliano movie I don't want to be part of
what becomes what could be a really
really damaging kind of return to 1970s
style institutionalization Eric Adams
isn't calling for um you know that
hospitalizing the kids who have Twitter
you know Tick Tock Tourette's right like
which is a thing that the kids like a go
on Tick Tock and then diagnose
themselves with with Tourette's because
they start doing a bunch of sort of
weird vocal ticks that aren't actually
Tourette's
but it's not
actually all that hard to imagine that
parents you know sort of get concerned
about their kids and then report this
these you know report their kids to
authorities and then somebody says well
look we have expanded power to commit
people who are who are mentally ill now
maybe maybe we can use that power
and you end up with with kids who are
just like going through basically normal
kid adolescent stuff committed because
of this yeah I think that's always a uh
a a serious concern but and I'll I'll go
to Matt because I know he likes any uh
any reference of a Van Halen
uh you know discography but I personally
know people whose lives were saved
almost certainly saved by 5150s uh you
know where they were perceived to be a
threat to themselves or others and they
were involuntarily held or they were
held in a hospital for you know 40 48 or
72 hours when the original hold gets uh
expires they do have to make a
recommendation and there is oversight
um you know of illegal nature that is
one way to make sure that
um something that is actually good and
useful and is a use of state power is
not abused um there's not a good history
of this because the you know throughout
uh certainly throughout the 20th century
um you know psychiatric evaluations have
always been used to control unruly
populations but there is a subset of
people in that who are violent uh to
others or violent to themselves that you
know really benefit as the society from
applying you know certain types of
interventions in a really
um you know consistent systematic and
supervised way
uh quick points here one uh 5150 is both
a better uh album and album name uh
certainly than ou812
um uh two uh refer everyone to uh CJ's
piece from uh about this Eric Adams plan
to involuntarily hospitalize mentally
ill homeless people will face legal
challenges it's the headline
um Annie goes through a lot of the legal
questions it's a very interesting I know
that you desperately want to move on but
you're not allowed I have to say one
more thing which is that
um which is that I did my uh senior
thesis in college on uh whether or not
there would be a legal way to write uh
contracts for people with cyclical or
recurring mental illness to establish
the terms under which they could be
committed
um and it was like uh and attempt to to
solve some of these problems in the
context of a Philosophy degree so a
spoiler I didn't solve any of them but
um maybe you caused them but I I think
that there is something there like that
we are we are under exploring ways in
which people who who do have periods of
clarity periods where they are amassed
in periods where they are okay
um to establish their own terms of when
they want to be helped and in what way
um it's not available for everyone but
more people than we think
um uh continuing my uh answer Catherine
um
I'm sorry yeah once you start talking
about Van Halen I'm asleep so sorry uh
uh no but that you mentioned bad policy
outcomes I would argue we have one right
now which is that there is not a day
that I go out into the society where I
live and go on a subway station where I
don't see where you do not defecate Matt
Welch uh where I don't see a jabbering
lunatic
um who I think might be a threat to uh
him or herself or to someone around them
um and that is the status quo that Eric
Adams is addressing I think that for
sure suderman is right that it will be
used badly where in New York things get
used badly by cops that's kind of what
happens
um and also
um it is a an actual problem I think the
my standard is uh and I don't know where
to draw the line to answer the the
actual question but is that there's
should be a notion towards that of of
public disorder disruption intoxication
uh craziness that that there's a line in
between where there's a there's a huge
gap in between
um just uh removing someone from a
public situation in which they're doing
um the sort of threatening uh either to
themselves or other people type of
things and then one flew of the Cuckoo's
Nest there's there's difference you can
okay okay come with me we're gonna go
over here and and we're gonna have
someone look at you doesn't necessarily
mean involuntarily a hospital commitment
um uh it's worth looking at and I that
we live in a society we live in a place
in a public place and I think there
should not be the default to expectation
that you're gonna get a sense of Menace
in public uh or or just uh grotesque
kind of Filth and I don't know what the
solution is but I think that identifying
it as a problem
um is fine
anyways let's go to our end of uh
podcast what we have been consuming uh
Nick do you want to lead us yeah and can
I just point out Matt that uh one floor
of the Cuckoo's Nest McMurphy is a
statutory rapist who then chooses to
fake mental illness to get into the
insane asylum because he Figures it's an
easier gig and one of the big reveals is
that almost everybody in the ward has
signed themselves in so it's a
complicated uh picture of uh even a
total mental institutions that end badly
for almost everybody involved and my
mother worked at the place where they
filmed that well and Salem uh Oregon uh
so uh what I have been consuming and um
uh torn because I saw a fantastic magic
show uh by Aussie wind which I'll I
think I'll talk about next week uh
instead of this week I am reading
Matthew Dalek uh the historians birchers
how the John Birch Society radicalized
the American right it's a history of the
John Birch Society and of Robert Welch
the uh candy magnate who uh founded it
in the late 50s uh with a kind of
Murderers Row of uh wealthy
industrialists including Fred Koch the
father of Charles Koch and David Koch
um to fight communism and moral
perversion and a variety of other kind
of insane conspiracy theories
um and what is great about Dalek's book
is that it kind of explains how the the
society came to be and how it actually
ended up in forming a lot of the right
he debunks the notion that National
Review and particularly William F
Buckley wrote the John Birch Society out
of the growing conservative movement
that was building steam around Barry
Goldwater he points out that Buckley cut
out Welch but not really the Birch
Society and that that's typical of many
people who ended up moving from
Goldwater into Reagan and beyond that
they uh publicly kind of attacked some
of the people in the Birch Society but
they believed many of their
conspiratorial theories especially about
stuff like sex education in school and
that the trilateral commission and that
globalization was a problem the most
interesting thing about the the book is
uh that he talks about how the John
Birch Society is a joke now I mean it's
no longer a powerful potent force of
ideas in its current form but that it
actually Through People Like Pat
Buchanan and people like Ron Paul many
of its Chief ideas and slogans such as
ending the fed and building walls to
protect us from an onslaught of mostly
Mexican immigrants have become and that
all trade agreements are somehow
capitulation to International communism
even if it doesn't exist anymore that
those ideas are alive and well in the
Contemporary uh Republican party a
fantastic book filled with lots of
interesting uh weird uh short uh
vignettes as well so birchers have the
John Birch Society radicalized American
right uh by Matthew Dalek highly
recommend it
Catherine what have you been consuming
uh you know I realized that I had
neglected to mention a book this
sometimes happens uh when people are
nice enough to send us early copies of
books uh I read them and then I say I'll
talk about that when it comes out and
then I forget
um so a while back I read
um Tim sandifer's new book freedoms
Furies uh and uh we have a review of IT
upcoming but um it's a it's a delightful
book about the uh three first ladies of
libertarianism uh Isabelle Patterson
Rose Wilder Lane and iron Rand I do
think we talked about this book briefly
maybe on the podcast I was trying to
remember but I didn't want to be sure I
mentioned it because it's it's good if
you're into a little bit of libertarian
history
um you know there's not been enough
biographical work done on these women
and they are fascinating weirdos I will
say a bunch of people on staff have made
the joke it every time you see this
title you do think it's Freedom's
furries which is a whole different book
um it is not that book I'm happy to
report yet to be written yet to be
written uh yet to yet to come into being
in our lives
um but uh yeah very good I did give a
blurb for this book which I must have uh
like taken some ambient and then written
this blurb because it's like the most
ridiculous it's like it's about Valerie
Jarrett I'm gonna carry this book around
in my purse and hit people upside the
head with it when they ask me why there
are no libertarian women is something
like what the blurbs next
and it's like I absolutely stand by it
but I'm not I don't know I don't know
what what is the uh does he explain why
the libertarian movement you know is
headed by like women or these three
women or what you know what what drove
them to uh kind of come up with this
joint philosophy he uh offers many
themes and notices definitive answers I
would say I'm not sure there is a
definitive answer when we are attempting
to generalize about demographic groups
but
um the book is delightful uh and uh in
many ways a better look at uh
particularly the work of uh Isabelle
Patterson than anything else that I've
read even including introductions to
collections of her work so
um it's a Cato book you can grab it and
I do think there is also a a panel that
was held at Cato last week featuring
reason's own uh Elizabeth Nolan Brown
talking about the book as well so you
can get your
libertarian lady content in whatever
form you prefer
a fun fact about Rose Wilder Lane uh uh
today uh is her 137th birthday hey happy
birthday dude
um Peter what have you been uh I was
just going to say I'm looking at the
cover of Freedom series which is a Cato
book and I'm disappointed that neither
the Statue of Liberty Uncle Sam or a
crying Eagle there's no Eagle perched on
the capitol Dome it's all disappointing
yeah
I watched the fablemans it's the new
fictionalized
semi-autobiographical film by Steven
Spielberg
um it's kind of like a Marvel Cinematic
Universe movie right like one of those
comic book movies where they're all
connected you know it's like filled with
sneaky Easter eggs and references and
fan theories except the universe in
question isn't a comic book Universe
it's Spielberg's life and the formative
films of the 1970s and 80s that sort of
made his career and the careers of his
contemporaries for example there's a
whole extended uh sort of allusion to
Brian De Palma's early work uh blow up
in particular
um and just references to like E.T and
Indiana Jones
Lucas all of the sort of
new Hollywood uh kind of figureheads as
well as a whole recurring bit about John
Ford that just pays off really
wonderfully with a delightful kicker
scene and so but mostly this is a a
movie about Spielberg's upbringing and
about his parents and so in some ways
it's an attempt to explain himself but
he doesn't really attempt to explain
himself directly instead he sort of
He suggests that he is that his work is
defined as a sort of as the interplay
between his parents um between his
engineer brain dad who was a sort of a
California computer scientist um and his
art brain mom who was a you know sort of
uh classically who in this movie is a
classically trained uh pianist who sort
of her art was stifled and she never
really got to perform
um and it's as if you asked Spielberg
tell me who you are and instead of
saying things directly about himself he
just replied by telling the story of his
parents and who they were in the
difficult dynamic between them because
that's how he sees himself or at least
that's how he presents himself here in
this movie right and so whatever that is
between his mom and his dad the troubles
they had the difficulty uh that that
created for um for Spielberg and his
siblings
um that is how he defines himself as
this sort of marriage of arch on the one
hand and kind of engineer brain on the
other hand and you can see it in his
films if you're a fan of of his work
right is that on the one hand you know
he has this very sort of Sacrament
emotional streak and on the other hand
he's just totally obsessed with the
technology of Cinema and sort of uh and
and the the the material sort of
physical stuff of it uh the movie's a
little bit too long at two and a half
hours but it it hit me pretty hard um in
part for personal reasons but partly
because it's a fairly effective portrait
of the interplay between art and life
and the ways in which art can be an
escape from life's pain and difficulties
as well as a healthy way of dealing with
them
one of the things that comes out when
you watch documentaries about Steven
Spielberg is that he blamed uh his dad
for um the dissolution or the the
dysfunction of uh his parents marriage
thought that he stepped out on on Mom
and then discovered pretty late in life
that it was the opposite it like made a
challenge of movies about how dads
totally suck
um early in his career and then he's
like whoops
in this movie The Teenage version of him
Sammy discovers that as a teenager and
in fact that De Palma sequence that I
was referencing it is a sequence of him
putting together home video or I guess
home home film cutting it together and
realizing through the power of Cinema
that he is seeing something that's
happening with his mother and with his
family that he couldn't see otherwise
because Cinema reveals the truth man
does uh his hilarious uh comedy 1941
Matt's favorite Spielberg movie uh get
mentioned it all it's the only Spielberg
movie I mean I I think it's pretty
obvious that that's the movie at the
heart of Spielberg's conception of
himself
yes
um speaking of Spielberg uh I watched a
a movie that was produced by his younger
sister Nancy on Nancy Spielberg um
documentary called above and beyond
great little tiny little documentary
from 2014
um about the development of the Israeli
Air Force and I know that doesn't sound
very interesting but uh it is uh it's
it's basically birthed in the uh
founding battles Wars of Israel's
formation in 1948 uh mostly American
Air Force vets World War II vets who've
flown some of whom had uh the tenuous at
best connections to Judaism let alone
the state of Israel which didn't really
exist
um but they were pressed uh into uh or
persuaded into serving
um and just like a ridiculous amount of
scheming to try to get any kind of
airplanes into the country at the time
there was a guy named Al Schwimmer a
Wheeler Dealer in like Burbank
California who like invented a fake
Airline
um and they flew parts inside of a big
plane and went to like South America and
then like Brazil and Africa and up here
and ended up training a very small unit
in Czechoslovakia and post-war and uh
and from there finally snuck into the
country right as five uh neighboring
countries were invading Israel in May of
1948 and it's just delightful
um a little like story of and they get a
whole bunch of the pilots and the people
including Pee-Wee Herman's Dad they
don't get him but they get Pee-wee
Herman and his mom talking about it's
totally crazily handsome father and so
the development of this mostly foreign
Air Force uh that uh turned the tide uh
in some of the wars at crucial moments
in very very unlikely uh forming
formation in this tiny little thing
above and beyond 2014
you can get on Netflix and Amazon and
elsewhere
um check it out I enjoyed it all right
that's all the time that we have
um again there's the final hours of the
webathon I think there's another match
going on by the time that you hear this
um so where you can double your
donations or someone's offered to double
the donations within a certain amount of
money Etc uh get in there while the
getting's good uh reason.com donate and
thank you for that and thank you uh very
much people were filling out the
donation form a whole lot of people said
nice things about the round table and it
wasn't just because I told you to
um there's volunteer stuff and a bunch
of nice stuff about reason and
interesting things too and and uh and uh
appreciate all that the great feedback
very fun um we'll have a post going up
soon uh that uh Corrals some of that
together
um listen to all of our podcasts at
reason.com podcast Nick do you have
anything to advertise Speak Easy wise or
any other events and uh yeah sure on
Wednesday we'll uh actually be rolling
the video and audio of the last species
it was Caitlin Bailey of Old Pros a sex
work worker Rights group that seeks to
decriminalize and destigmatize sex work
it was by Common acclimation the best of
these live events that we've done she's
just a fantastic presence and so it's
you know very uh entertaining but also
edifying and then on January 4th uh
Wednesday January 4th will be the next
species and we'll be talking with Andrew
tatarsky who helped Pioneer the concept
of harm reduction rather than
prohibition when it comes to drug
treatment drug laws and kind of drug
policy so
all right up thank you again we'll catch
you next week goodbye
[Music]